bonjour christian jacob bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
président des républicains également
député l air de seine et marne vous ne
vous représentez pas on va en parler
beaucoup de sujets à évoquer avec vous
ce matin la campagne de la droite pour
les législatives votre attitude
vis-à-vis de la république en marche
durant cette campagne serez vous dans
une opposition frontale un soutien à
emmanuel macron est il possible les
auditeurs de france inter vous interroge
au 01 45 24 7000 ou via les réseaux
sociaux et l'appli france inter je
voudrais qu'on commence tout de même
christian jacob cet entretien par ce qui
se passe à gauche le conseil national du
parti socialiste doit se prononcer ce
soir sur l'accord qui a été trouvé hier
avec la france insoumise les verts et
les communistes ont déjà dit oui comment
est ce que vous regardez cette union qui
est en train de s'organiser à gauche
avec jalousie avec 30 avec déception
c'est le problème de la gauche c'est pas
le mien mais mais c'est tout et
n'importe quoi je me mets à la place du
du militant socialiste profondément
républicain qui s'aligne derrière la
france insoumise derrière des individus
comme ta aboaf je rappelle que cet
individu traitait les musulmans qui
manifestaient contre le terrorisme à une
marche contre le terrorisme les traité
de collabo
qui a insulté une jeune syndicaliste
policière en la traitant d' arabes de
service
les socialistes se range derrière cela
avec des positions sur tous les sujets
avec des des gens qu'on connaît la
france insoumise la france insoumise ils
ont une idée c'est le chaos le blocage
il ne pense qu'à ça le chaos absolu la
6ème république
cette mise en scène est invraisemblable
alors après plus sérieusement tout le
monde sait que bien évidemment il ya
absolument zéro chance et dieu merci que
jean luc mélenchon devienne premier
ministre tout ça et de la tambouille
2 2 comme tambouille électoraliste
montre d'ailleurs la gauche tu crois pas
en disant mais bon après tout
j'ai envie de dire notre époque on
aurait dit l'argent n'a pas d'odeur la
du moment que j'ai une circonscription
je suis tranquille ma foi on va essayer
on va essayer d'y aller 20 tout tout
tout ça c'est séduit les électeurs de
gauche semblent attendre 7 millions
quand on leur pose la question dans les
autres y sont majoritaires et je pense
qu'ils s'interrogent sur les positions
qui sont celles de la france insoumise
et croyez moi j'ose espérer qu'ils vont
qui vont revenir ceci étant c'est pas
c'est pas notre sujet nous on a on est
ce que ça change quelque chose pour
votre position absolument est ce que
vous dites est ce que nous devons
continuer à rester pour celles non non
nous on est indépendants on est sur une
île vous savez jean luc mélenchon est
dans le même rôle qui était celui de
marine le pen marine le pen à l'élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron avait besoin de
quelqu'un pour jouer l'idiot utile
c'est ce que marine le pen c'est
dépendra fait au moment des
présidentielles
et là il a fait la même chose avec avec
jean luc mélenchon je pense qu'il faut
rester sérieux ces élections
législatives c'est la représentation de
577 territoire luminance moi je
j'appelle l'ensemble des français à
s'interroger là d'ssus d'erquy pour
représenter les problématiques qui se
posent sis en zone urbaine les
problématiques de 2,2 de logement de
transport de sécurité en zone rurale on
est sur d'autres d'autres problématiques
mais c'est ça qui est important qui pour
représenter et c'est pour ça que je
crois à l'ancrage territorial de nos
élus et c'est là que les républicains
nous faisons la différence nous avons un
ancrage territorial analyse n'est
peut-être pas la même en ce moment du
côté de la direction du ps le ps et ee
l'air étaient face à face il y a dix ans
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle le ps termine la
présidentielle un peu plus de 1% vous un
peu au-delà des 4 % qu'est ce qui
explique cet effondrement parallèle
christian jacob il n'est pas tout à fait
pas parallèle il ya il ya un groupe de
100 de plus de 100 députés chez les
républicains et puis surtout un ancrage
territorial qu'on a vus aux élections
municipales départementales et
régionales il ya beaucoup de maires
socialistes des présentations pas dans
les mêmes proportions les républicains
présidentielle fut un moment mais bien
sûr mais pour les républicains je
rappelle que ces 56 % des villes de
france qui sont gérés par les exécutifs
les républicains pour ce qui est de la
présidentielle le sujet effectivement
nous n'avons pas réussi à ouvrir les
mâchoires entre d'un côté
emmanuel macron de l'autre côté les
extrêmes et marine le pen et nous avons
échoué on va pas tourner autour du pot
en revanche ces élections législatives
c'est d'une tout autre nature c'est
pourquoi nous refusons l'idée du parti
unique d'abord parce qu'on ne se
reconnaît en rien à la politique menée
par emmanuel macron c'est l'échec total
sur ce quinquennat et ceux d'entre nous
de chez nous qui sont allés vous
souvenez qu'un certain nombre de
ministres à commencer par le premier
ministre edouard philippe bruno le maire
gérald darmanin pour faire quoi quelle
est leur bilan à la fin edouard philippe
il a mis le feu sur tous les
ronds-points de france en étant
complètement fermé aucune comprenant pas
le pays au moment où il a augmenté les
taxes a mis les girondins affrontent
abba complètement attendait complètement
rappelons quand même la jeunesse des
choses c'est l'augmentation des taxes
sur les carburants que nous dénonçons à
l'époque edouard philippe ne veut rien
entendre
il prend cette responsabilité de dire
circulez ya rien à voir et voilà ce que
ça génère bruno le maire -ministre de la
de l'économie et des finances c'est la
gabegie financière totale avant la crise
du coc vite bien entendu avant la crise
de l'aco vide le taux de chômage au plus
bas une tentation le concert
c'était pas ça le on peut pas dire que
ce soit lié à son action non qu'on
puisse dire l'augmentation des dépenses
publiques sous françois hollande 1,4
pour cent d'augmentation par an quand
emmanuel macron arrive avec
effectivement edouard philippe bruno le
maire on passe à 2,6 d'augmentation par
an c'est-à-dire quand vous avez une
augmentation de la dépense publique ça
se traduit par quoi augmentation des
déficits augmentation de la dette et
donc augmentation des impôts étant vous
avez 10 à ces derniers moi valérie
pécresse dans sa campagne emmanuel
macron a été réélu est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya une possibilité qu'il
n'est pas de majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale ça c'est aux
français d'en décider moi je crois sur
le projet qui est le nôtre la nécessité
d'intervenir très fortement sur le
pouvoir d'achat le coût de l'énergie
aujourd'hui est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation
c'est pour ça que nous faisons nous
allons faire une série de propositions
notamment sur la baisse du prix des
carburants et il y a nous avons la
chance était de l'argent aux finances
publiques certaines mesures oui mais
sauf que c'est l'état des finances
publiques et changea comme ça va coûter
cher sauf que nous proposons une règle
d'or c'est à dire d'arrêter la gabegie
financière la règle d'or c'est de ne pas
augmenter davantage de la dette du
niveau elle est aujourd'hui par rapport
au produit intérieur brut c'est ce qui
existe dans dans d'autres dans d'autres
cas moi je pense que nous avons
justement la ressource avec nos
candidats avec des élus ancré sur le
terrain en proximité avec leurs
concitoyens et qui sont pas dans les
petites manoeuvres politiciennes qui
sont ceux de de monsieur macro aider des
gens qui l'entourent votre objectif vous
avez un peu plus de 100 députés
aujourd'hui c'est d'en avoir le maximum
d'accord c'est pas très ambitieux
le bâtiment que ça peut être 30 ça peut
être le maximum c'est que je ont été
recensés d'aller cessé d'aller au delà
mais mais le sujet enfin les les choses
se pose pas comme ça c'est là je crois
au bon sens et à la réalité du terrain
qui pour nous représenter un député
c'est celui qui va porter la parole de
sa de sa circonscription et donc on a
besoin d'avoir des gens qui comprennent
les réalités du terrain qu'ils soient en
proximité avec leurs concitoyens
exactement l inverse de tous les
candidats tous les parlementaires en
marche qui ont totalement échoué sur
cela c'est pour ça qu'ils réussissent
pas aux municipales aux départementales
ou régionales c'est parce que on est
dans un parisianisme une bureaucratie
qui est incomprise par l'ensemble de la
france donc pas d'accord avec la blick
en marche avant
chaque jour nos couleurs vous expliquiez
la semaine dernière dans le journal le
figaro je vous cite nous sommes tournés
vers les législatives sans être fongible
ni dans le lepénisme ni dans le
maquereau nisme vous est ce que vous
mettez macro nice mais lepénisme sur le
même plan non bien évidemment que non
ces deux histoires totalement totalement
différentes et qui n'ont rien à voir à
ce que vous êtes à égal 2 e en or marine
lorraine et maintenant ils imaginaient
aujourd'hui qu' un accord entre les
républicains et le front national
ici à france inter qu est-ce que
j'entendrais ce que la gauche est en
train de faire cerisy avis était
totalement ailleurs sur d'accord
c'est quoi une accusation c'est une
reconnaissance d'une très grande radio
et sa ligne éditoriale
mais
bien évidemment que non ça n'a aucune
comparaison
simplement ça veut dire que nous sommes
indépendants nous sommes là pour
représenter les territoires sont les
nôtres si je prends quelques enjeux
majeurs les retraites décaler l'âge de
la retraite jusqu'à 65 ans était dans le
projet de valérie pécresse s'est porté
par emmanuel macron la transition
écologique construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires là encore on
retrouve cela dans les deux programmes
pour les entreprises la baisse des
impôts de production là encore ce sont
des propositions que vous faites et que
la république en marche fait vous avez
quand même plus de points communs que de
différences avec la république en marche
aujourd'hui la différence c'est que les
déclarations vous venez d'évoquer les
positions dans marche on est dans le
boniment on est dans le boniment qu'est
ce qui a été fait sur les retraites rien
mais vous êtes d'accord
non non non non il ya une grande
différence nous on est d'accord pour le
faire oui on n'est pas d'accord pour
faire des boniments emmanuel macron on
le sait est incapable de porter quelques
réformes que ce soit à force de faire du
dut en même temps de vouloir en donner à
tout le monde souvenez vous sur les
retraites sur les retraites il avait
annoncé on allait voir ce qu'on allait
voir c'est l'équivalent de la création
de la sécurité sociale par le général de
gaulle ah bah oui on était bien loin de
tout cela incapable de faire une réforme
des retraites parce que incapable
d'avoir une ligne sur quoi que ce soit
c'était avant la crise du que vides
trois ans de parlotte pour calais pour
dire qu'il reprendrait forme des
retraites ensuite six mois avant la
présidentielle
on va refaire la réforme des retraites
ensuite à la fin de la présidentielle
ils arrêtent ils réellement ses 65 ans
en disant ce n'est pas un dogme rien
n'est fait sur le nucléaire sur le
nucléaire mais souvenez vous il ya trois
ans et emmanuel macron qui décide la red
en quelque sorte du nucléaire c'est à
dire de passer la part du nucléaire dans
l'énergie de 75% à 50% de fermer
fessenheim
c'est à dire de stopper le nucléaire
maintenant il redit le compte et c'est
tout et n'importe quoi c'est à dire où
aucune vision sur rien c'est ce qui fait
la différence nous sur les retraites
nous avons toujours eu la même ligne sur
le nucléaire nous avons toujours eu la
même ligne nous n'avons jamais changé
christian jacob vous tapez on l'entend
ce matin efforts sur emmanuel macron
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux maires
les républicains de saint-etienne gaël
perdriau qui dit mais si mon parti
continue de refuser l'ouverture il
risque de devenir une secte écoutez je
laisse à ses responsabilités donc on a
une ligne
qui a été défendu j'ai présenté celle de
l'indépendance celle de l'honneur
de tenir d'avoir des convictions fortes
de tenir ses engagements
elle était soutenue par 90% du bureau
politique alors moi je respecte les 10%
qui ne sont pas en accord sur cette
ligne bien évidemment mais un peu
d'humilité de modestie ne nuit pas non
plus que se passerait-il pour des
députés l'est républicain sortant qui
soutiendraient emmanuel macron christian
jacob nous là aussi la position est très
claire il n'y a pas de double
appartenance politique c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas être l air et la
république en marche on ne peut pas être
et l'air et front national on ne peut
pas être et l'air et les filles on ne
peut pas être l air et reconquête on est
et l'air on est nous mêmes on a
l'honnêteté de se présenter face à nos
électeurs nous mêmes sur notre solide de
kong de conviction sans petites
combinaisons à part c'est un message que
vous en voyez par exemple à damien abad
qui est le patron actuel des députés
hier à la salle de s'interroger c'est à
messac d'abord il est toujours sein de
s'interroger avant de prendre une
décision en revanche quand une position
est prise est allé prise près clairement
dans notre famille politique et bien on
se rallie bien évidemment à la position
ultra majoritaire elisabeth nous appelle
du département des hautes-pyrénées
bonjour elizabeth
bonjour
[Musique]
je viens de bien sûr je me découvre que
vous venez de dire prononcé le monde et
par l'hôte boon ou non tout et n'importe
quoi en parlant de maquereaux et son
équipe mais quand est ce que vous allez
en fait assumer votre partie d'échecs
voilà un élection présidentielle et puis
ben envisagé quand même une politique
d'opposition
six fois réellement constructive
envers systématiquement à appuyer la
haine et le
voilà donc c'est qu'ils les frères mais
on sait que vous ne cherchez pas
vraiment le bien du pays merci pour
votre question elisabeth christian jacob
vous répond des deux choses d'abord nous
avons toujours été dans une pause dans
une opposition constructive nous avons
toujours assumé et gelé moi-même assumer
en étant pendant dix ans président de
mon groupe parlementaire de voter des
textes qu'il est dans le bon sens oui
nous avons voté à peu près 40% des des
textes sur les cinq sur les cinq
dernières années
ensuite bien évidemment l'échec de la
présidentielle je l'évoquais on va pas
se voiler la face on l'assument on se
met aussi au aussi ce que l'on
représente sur le terrain quand près de
60% des français nous font confiance
pour gérer les collectivités
territoriales ça n'est pas le fait du
hasard c'est parce que nous avons cet
ancrage territorial
cette proximité avec avec nos
concitoyens et c'est cela qui doit être
reconnu au moment des élections
législatives et puis encore une fois on
n'est pas dans des combinaisons
d'appareil dans des petites magouilles
politiciennes on assume les idées qui
sont les nôtres et on se présente avec
honneur et avec indépendance devant les
français denis nous appel de chambéry
bonjour denis ou bonjour et merci aussi
pour vos émissions bonjour monsieur
jacob bonjour je
rajoutais et soutenir ce qu'a dit la
personne juste avant mais c'est jacob
l'excès en tout est un des fonds énormes
pire que tout l'été faux et tout était
une erreur pendant les cinq dernières
années et qui après vous avez voté 40%
des lois d'ailleurs complètement en
contradiction parce que si tout avait
été mauvais vue sans rien lui voté
agressivité passerait pas d'autre mot
alors que vous parlez d'une vie qu'est
bon madame pécresse a peut-être pas été
excellente mais votre coupon dans le
fait pas
interpellation de denis de chambéry
christian jacob écoutez j'habite de nier
avoir je regrette qu'il sort du peuple
même soutien que moi jus pour valérie
pécresse c'est à dire un soutien de de
tous les jours malheureusement l'échec a
été là il faut le il faut le constater
le reproche que je fais sur ce
quinquennat je l'évoqué avec des
chiffres qui sont pas les miens qui sont
ceux qui sont connus c'est à dire que la
dépense publique a explosé avant la
crise du coc vide ce qui est qui génère
le fait qu'on a plus de mille milliards
de dettes supplémentaires
que l'on a des déficits que ces déficits
génère de l'impôt et des taxes qui
étouffe les français au quotidien que
sur la sécurité en cinq ans on est à
plus de 40 d'une augmentation de 40%
des tentatives d'homicides à plus de 30%
des violences sur personne tout ça je
n'invente pas c'est sans la renier jeu
mais quand des textes vont dans le bon
sens on assume de les voter mais
simplement on essaie d'être objectif sur
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
et l'incapacité de réformer penser que
c'est ce gouvernement le seul
gouvernement depuis 40 ans qui était
incapable de porter une réforme des
retraites incapables même françois
hollande qui est pas un de mes amis a
apporté une réforme des retraites et ses
environs ont été incapables on a
plusieurs messages qui vont dans ce sens
notamment sur l'application france inter
jean pierre pourquoi vouloir vous
différencier d'un gouvernement qui a
trois ministres qui ont participé à la
primaire de droite en 2017 et qui
appliquent déjà des politiques de droite
et puis question de jean-pierre je
trouve question constat je trouve
lamentable l'attitude de l'état major de
votre parti vis-à-vis de valérie
pécresse j'ai voté pour madame pécresse
je ne suis pas un électeur et l'air mais
loin de me réjouir l'attitude de
messieurs sarkozy et woerth monte
écoeuré il termine par ce mot trahison
c'est une trahison
que ont
fait ou ou que vous pensez de la part de
nicolas sarkozy et d'eric vous la mettez
pas dans le même deux choses totalement
différentes d'abord nicolas sarkozy a
été président de la république était un
grand président de la république moi
j'étais fier d'être à ses côtés j'étais
à l'époque président de groupe du groupe
parlementaire ce qui n'a rien à voir
vous là l'attitude d'eric woerth je la
trouve effectivement assez pathétique
c'est à dire bon président de la
commission des finances est lu par
par notre groupe parlementaire par par
l'opposition qui qui nous quitte pour
aller en marche mais qui s'accroche à sa
présidence à sa voiture son indemnité
enfin je trouve ça assez pathétique pour
accepter les raisons financières
d'effectifs ou non mais mais la réalité
c'était ça vous dit c'est pour garder sa
voiture et ben non
il devait remettre son mandat avoir
l'honneur de remettre son mandat quand
on était comme lui ministre du budget
avec des hautes responsabilités
bon là aussi un peu de dignité dans dans
l'action et nicolas sarkozy qui a été
reçu en début de semaine par emmanuel
macron c'est normal que je l' ai dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'un ancien chef de
l'état puissent être reçus par le chef
de l'état après sur leur conversation
moi j'ai pris leur futur gouvernement il
reçoit nicolas sarkozy
sûrement utile tout ça regèle mais enfin
vous n'avez pas assisté au rendez vous
et moi non plus non mais non mais enfin
d'accord moi je ne sais pas ce qu'ils se
sont dit nous nous avons une position
encore une fois sur une ligne qui fait
90 % dans notre toujours compliqué
aujourd'hui de critiquer nicolas
compliqué parce que dans la boue en
quelque sorte c'est pas un tabou c'est
que je ne le ferai pas parce que encore
une fois je reconnais l'action qui était
la sienne et en plus de ça j'ai des
liens d'amitié mais après yanling
politique ligne politique c'est celle
que je défends c'est à dire
l'indépendance c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas se retrouver dans le projet d'
emmanuel macron ce qui veut pas dire
qu'on ne vote pas des textes relance qui
vont dans le bon sens bien évidemment ce
qu'on a toujours fait mais c'était un
quinquennat ont rien avec on rompt la
vue je l'évoquais sur la sécurité je
l'évoqué sur la dépense publique je les
évoquer sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ministres qui certes était dans notre
famille politique qui sont allés au
gouvernement ce résultat pour rien sauf
servir effectivement leur intérêt
personnel ça joue bien que les ai eu du
plaisir à être ministre mais la réalité
qu'est ce qu'ils ont apporté à l'intérêt
général rien nous avons parlé de
l'accord en route à gauche au début de
cet entretien christian jacob et vos
propos font réagir martial arènes
bonjour martial oui bonjour bonjour où
l'on joué vous faire remarquer comment
dire pour moi un petit peu le meilleur
indicateur du fait que la nouvelle union
populaire ça a l'air de fonctionner
c'est la quantité de commentaires on
reçoit à la fois soit à toutes les
échelles à la radio sur d'abord devions
utiliser ça ne se fera jamais et qui
maintenant disent c'est n'importe quoi
ce sont des islamistes ce sont je ne
sais pas quoi en tout cas sa part dans
la caricature
et seconde remarque juste je remarque
d'ailleurs que vous avez l'air de tester
les run dans une certaine mesure pour
moi la seule différence entre ol et om
et l herbe dès que les remises fondu et
l'air mais ce ne sont pas vous et
j'aimerais bien par exemple que vous
évoquez une loi ou à un bulletin ou
n'importe quoi qu'ils aient pu cher que
vous n'auriez pas c'est pendant ce
quinquennat voilà merci à vous marciel
j'ajoute sur vos propos sur la france
insoumise juliette comment peut-on
parler ainsi de la france insoumise
alors que 20 % des électeurs se sont
prononcés en sa faveur moi je parle des
candidats de la france insoumise qui
vont présenter est bon mais c'est la
responsabilité des électeurs de gauche
veut dire s'ils se retrouvent tous sous
cette bannière de l'extrême gauche
partout c'est eux qui à ses yeux qui en
qui en décideront
simplement
je n'ai rien de commun de commun avec
eux ce n'est pas être
rebuté
l'auditeur parlait de haine à l'instant
oui c'est pas du tout dans ceux de sens
dans ce sentiment je l'ait jamais été
mais c'est une ligne que je ne partage
absolument pas quant à la question à la
dernière question sur des textes qui
aurait été présentée je n'aurais pas
voté ce que j'aurais voté c'est une
réforme des retraites quand je parle de
boniments c'est quand on explique que
l'on va
augmenter les pensions des retraités
mais on ne fait pas de réforme des
retraites et pourquoi le gouvernement a
échoué en cinq ans sur la réforme des
retraites et qui nous explique
bizarrement là aujourd'hui qui va leur
faire il ne l'affrontement bien
évidemment il nous reste un tout petit
peu de temps pour prendre la question de
françois depuis errani bonjour françois
oman jouera bonjour france inter bonjour
christian jacob joué j'avais une
douloureuse et parce que
quand il ya des élections vous avez
affirmé que les candidats aient l'air se
présenterait sous l'étiquette ehlers moi
ce que je constate est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous à nous affirmer
aujourd'hui que tous les candidats qui
se présenteraient sur leurs affiches
figureraient et l'air parce que bien
souvent il ya une ambiguïté où on a un
candidat de droite ou avec des
révélations d'affiche diverses et
variées mais on n'a pas véritablement le
nom elle qui apparaît et les gens sont
appelés à voter quand même beaucoup plus
sûres effectivement
une version de droite que sur une
version d énervement les républicains
merci françois pour cette question
précise alors figurera bien sûr le sigle
les républicains mais également avec
nous nos alliés centristes donc le parti
centriste et éluder y donc ça chaque
candidat reçoit le soutien et
l'investiture de ces trois familles
politiques après sur sur l'affiché logo
c'est de la responsabilité du du
candidat moi je pense que l'on gagne
toujours avec la clarté on peut être
candidat et l'air 100 m nerfs sur la
chine si on met ait l'air mais mais
ensuite sur la manière dont dans
l'affiché du sol chevauchant petit os en
gros pas si l'on met la tête du candidat
c'est quand même cescom en priorité et
ensuite les soutiens des trois des trois
familles politiques et bien évidemment
enfin peut-être enfin d'autres mettent
parfois l'union de la droite et du
centre est en dessous on est dans le
détail moi ce que je crois c'est qu'on
gagne toujours à être clair est
il ya honnête sur les convictions qui
sont les nôtres et sur la la défense de
notre projet est donc à pas se cacher à
sa fiche et très clairement en 15
secondes pas de regret de ne pas
repartir à la bataille christian jacob
non j'étais c'est une décision que
j'avais prise il ya il ya cinq ans déjà
j'étais six ans enfin six fois pardon
députés élus et réélus après on peut
toujours dire qu'on fait un septième ou
huitième mandat mais je trouve qu'au
bout de schiste c'est bien l'homme sont
jeunes merci à vous christian jacob
invité de france inter ce matin
président des républicains